one billion covet 19 vaccines and a
pledge to continue funding development
across africa but can china avoid
criticism over taking advantage of
natural resources and saddling
developing nations with unsustainable
debt this is inside story
hello i'm sahil rahman welcome to the
program china's president xi jinping has
promised african nations 1 billion
coronavirus vaccines and has pledged to
continue economic investment in the
region
she made the comments virtually as part
of the annual forum on the china-africa
cooperation as the two-day summit in
senegal comes to a close
china emphasized how crucial the
partnership is
china is africa's largest trading
partner with nearly 190 billion dollars
in trade so let's take a closer look at
china's long-term investment plans in
africa chinese foreign direct investment
in the continent was almost three
billion dollars in 2020 totaling almost
50 billion overall almost a third of
that investment has gone into the
construction infrastructure development
areas now that's helped make china
africa's biggest trading partner it's
also given china premier access to
needed raw materials to fuel its economy
it's the largest importer of copper and
cobalt from africa most of it extracted
by chinese financed companies
but this investment has also come with a
heavy debt burden chinese finance comes
with an average 4.2 percent interest
rate far higher than other international
options
well let's bring in our guests now
joining me from nairobi is hasan kanenji
the director of horn international
institute for strategic studies in
london anthony goldman he's the head of
pro media consulting which advises
companies and institutions
on business and political risk in africa
and from beijing china we have andy mock
a senior research fellow at the center
for china and globalization i will
welcome gentlemen to all of you mr
kanenji can i just give you the first
question i mean to understand
china's contact with africa we have to
sort of go back to its origin and first
contact you might say between the two uh
continents nearly 500 years ago back in
the 15th century
early trade was that initial
contact that they had it was very
important and it still remains important
today
yeah it is indeed true that the
interaction between
china and the african continent uh go
back hundreds of years ago
at the time of cause that preceded uh
colonialism and this is something that
is also been established based on the
evidence of chinese presence along the
african coast and along the east african
coast that actually go back
further about a thousand years ago now
the transactions were
significantly modified of course in the
period following the second world war
in which after the coming to power of
mao zedong the communist party saw it
fit to work with a lot of liberation
movements on the continent and they
remained very supportive especially on
the left-wing side of african politics
for much of the cold war and i think uh
that is paying dividends especially in
the post-cold war period in which china
has sought to entrench those relations
further by establishing a more presence
in terms of robust economic as well as
military posture let me bring in anthony
goldman there because you've very neatly
brought me to that
post-second world war uh period and the
cold war uh andy that obviously saw
china you might say come in under the
radar dare i say it into into africa to
deal with those governments who are more
left-leaning
more sympathetic and of course china
itself and i'm quoting here from mount
to dong here
where he also described himself and
china as being part of the third world
they they recognized and had an
affiliation with parts of africa that
was very important in building up that
relationship
yes i think that uh
as part of that i think that there were
projects that uh
that
china began to engage with following on
from that support for countries in
southern africa so for example building
uh infrastructure railway between
tanzania and zambia that was seen as a
kind of a landmark thing of the 1970s a
landmark achievement in terms of
infrastructure mostly i think uh in that
period in
of the cold war the most visible
presence was actually
the uh
tensions between china and taiwan and
that uh you could go to african capitals
and see a competition if you like
between taiwanese built uh a palace or a
chinese-built uh national stadium and in
a sense i think there's still an echo of
some of that competition uh even today
but china is still anxious that
countries in africa don't look too far
to to taiwan for support but on the
whole i think the tilt
since the end of the cold war has been
much more in favor of china building up
actual you know economic ties based less
uh solely around strategy and diplomacy
as support for uh the ever-increasing
ever demands of chinese industry let me
bring in andy mock there i know you
wanted to come in uh hearing our two
previous speakers there andy and without
giving our viewers a full history lesson
which this program is not certainly
china's influence in the region and on
the continent has been long-standing and
continues to be certainly
after this conversational virtual
conversation they've had this year
no indeed sahil so i would just very
briefly start with 1949 with the
founding of the people's republic of
china and you quoted mao zedong i think
from day one of the establishment of new
china the philosophy has been to
uh
treat africa with a spirit of sincerity
genuine cooperation and mutual respect
and i think that has been
a common thread linking the decades
since uh 1949 to today in terms of
understanding
by the relationship between china and
the continent would you say though that
um you say that they wanted to try and
treat all of those countries with equal
respect but there was also this cold war
between russia and the united states or
russia and the west
and they wanted to gain influence in
africa as well
do you think that china itself at that
time was also
obviously very mindful of what its
position could be or should be in the
future if and when the cold war ended
no certainly and the world has changed
tremendously since the early 50s so
geopolitically of course we've seen the
cold war between the soviet union the
united states and china played an
important part of that
geostrategically
and from that perspective uh i think
certainly
uh africa has been seen as a
battleground maybe uh even a playground
for of course colonial powers and i
think today as well we've seen in the
news i'm sure
all this talk of the united states
wanting to contest
chinese influence in africa but i think
one of the things to point out too you
touched on zeal is that um china has
always seen itself as part of the
developing world and i think rightly so
uh today uh cj ping says that china will
never forget that it is a member of the
uh
group of developing nations
and if we go back to what deng xiaoping
said about crossing the river by feeling
the stones i think what china has very
clearly enunciated in the last few years
is that it has found a way across the
river and now is willing to show other
people that path but without imposing
any type of ideology foreign ideology or
any kind of political or economic
mechanisms along with that and letting
africa other parts of the world develop
on their own terms okay anthony can i
then bring you in because obviously
china may see itself in whatever terms
it wants to but china is viewed by some
i.e the u.s in terms of its influence
across africa as a bit of a bogeyman i
mean they need a new enemy you might say
sometimes this time an economic enemy
and that is china
yes i think there's something in that i
mean i i think
i think certainly um at the beginning of
china's new economic engagement with
africa maybe 20 or so years ago perhaps
some of that rhetoric about you know
china being you know a fair apartment
not having a kind of a neo-colonial
agenda that china had its own experience
of
rapid growth and uh taking people out of
poverty industrialization that might
have had some currency i don't think it
really does uh anymore i don't think
anybody in africa uh really thinks like
that china is just you know another
potential source of uh financing and
other potential and a competitor for
projects and i think uh i was speaking
uh earlier this week with a
senior official in in an african country
said that perhaps it might be better if
people worried less about uh what china
thought of uh africa and more what uh
africa needed from its partners and i
think that
this uh the competition if you like uh
between uh rival powers doesn't do a
great deal for the people who ultimately
are meant to benefit in terms of
actually providing projects on their own
merits you know projects that are
commercially viable and have less kind
of of this uh
rhetorical baggage from you know that
makes more sense perhaps in washington
or even beijing than perhaps in burkina
faso or zambia we'll talk about the
specific economic economics in a moment
but um hassan kanenji can i just come
back to you you know africa
itself and its uh subsequent nations
within the continent have had to deal
with military gurus cross-border
confrontation climate change and famine
ethnic rivalries each country has its
own beset problems how has china in your
opinion been able to maintain
a good relationship with all of those
different sorts of regimes and
governments when they've had this whole
range of problems across the continent
i think china has learned from some of
the mistakes uh that were done by
previous powers especially europe and
the united states in part because he
does not choose governments for africans
and that is very attractive to african
leadership which more often sometimes is
not accountable and sometimes they tend
to be authoritarian
secondly uh african countries have found
the path of japanese growth relatable in
part because it's a country that is
previously being classified as a third
world even though that's a political
conference
but increasingly of course it's moving
into the higher stages of being an
advanced economy but uh thirdly
i think because china us looks at africa
as a partner and does not seek
to
involve in the channel affairs of
indigenous afghan countries it has
allowed both friends and enemies within
the continent to actually be able to
work with china irrespective of which
government of the day is in power and i
think because of the kind of relations
that it sought to build
while it was relatively poor and the
the perception of equal partnership that
is seeking to build even at the cost of
increased debt trap that most african
countries are finding themselves in uh
china has been able to be successful in
areas where for instance the west uh has
failed and in part also because it does
not have the granule baggage and it's
not viewed as negatively as some of the
western metropolis even though as i did
mention there is an increasing a sense
that a number of countries are sinking
further into chinese state that is going
to prove unsustainable in the near
future there is this uh anthony goldman
there is this real debate going on isn't
there at the moment about
africa's resources what china wants and
what it needs it for in terms of its
manufacturing
and product base i mean when we look at
uh some of the statistics six countries
make up 68 percent of total exports
angola accounting for a third angola
libya
import or oil
from gabon gabon also imports oil and
manganese the republic of congo a series
of reports we've had on al jazeera news
you know and the democratic republic of
congo
extracts cobalt and copper i mean
there's a lot of natural resources that
china requires and
and the balance of payments is lopsided
as well you know what africa is able to
buy off china is is far less than what
china you might say takes from africa
no you make a very good point i mean
africa is not a country obviously
there's a huge
distinction between
the most favored trading partners and
some of those countries where maybe
china has much less of a relationship
and uh angola south africa are
particularly important uh i think we've
seen some growth in in west africa in
recent years china's tried to crack
nigeria with uh different degrees of uh
success but i think that uh on top of
the uh the the products that uh the the
raw materials typically that
uh china seeks to secure from africa the
energy security mineral security it
needs uh to support growth in that sense
it is fairly familiar to the kind of
patterns of economic engagement that
other uh industrialized countries uh
seek with uh africa one of the
differences perhaps is that china as a
major manufacturer of cheap uh and
cheaper products is that actually
there's quite a large informal trade
that's perhaps not always captured in
the official uh data between uh
china and africa quite a lot of that has
dipped obviously because of the pandemic
and the lack of travel over the last 18
months or so but until that they were
regular uh flights from direct from
china to parts of africa where small
traders even were going picking up
petty goods you know the things to sell
at market so i think that
the picture isn't always captured by the
big data if you like and i think that
there has been quite a deep relationship
from the top as well as uh the bottom
with africa even where china's strategic
interests do focus more on a particular
and small set of countries
andy mock
xi jinping announced the fact that there
would be less money being invested in
africa as a continent that can be
interpreted in many ways one of the ways
that it has been interpreted is that
china is
listening to what africa needs and
adapting its finances accordingly others
are suggesting that china is walking
away from africa what's your
interpretation of it
well i think the reality is much more
complex and nuanced
then to portrayed in such black and
white binary terms and i want to back up
a little bit to what the earlier
speakers said about china learning uh
some lessons
from the european
and perhaps the americans
in dealing with africa i would say it's
much more profound than that and that
china brings a true sense of empathy in
working with
the continent because
china has not that long ago struggled
with exactly the same issues
high
mortality rates malnutrition etc etc so
i think that it's coming from a very
very different place and the philosophy
the governing
principles or non-interference and
respect for each country's systems and
choices so i think that allows it to
deal much more effectively
with the countries of africa now that
then
leads us to the current question which
you just asked what is china doing now
or going forward i think it's important
to recognize that china does not look at
africa as a patron client relationship
but again if we think about it as mutual
respect win-win um there will always be
adjustments uh we look at uh
trade with africa it's been about 200
billion dollars a year over the last
five years or so but it goes up and down
uh based on exogenous factors as well as
uh domestic market considerations
so i think that the longer term
direction is much much greater uh
interaction and integration with africa
but we have to see
how that unfolds in terms of investments
uh trade
details um all kinds of other things uh
technical assistance i believe china
provides about 45 percent of its uh
foreign aid to africa
uh andy let me just bring in uh mr
kanenji you were nodding your head in i
think in agreement with some of the
points that were being made but can i
also add to whatever you might want to
say now in that xi jinping has said that
he wants to open green lanes for african
agricultural exports he wants to speed
up inspection and quarantine procedures
to increase the scope of products with
zero tariff treatment to help achieve a
goal
one assumes of equality of trade
equality is that how you see it
that is in part a response to increasing
sentiment on the continent that the
balance of payments are heavily in favor
of china and therefore china is trying
to look for ways in which they can
appease the african partners
it is important though
that uh they still increased appeal of
china uh while economically it's seeking
sometimes often to make some of the
african economies uh in its own image uh
by following its own path it does not
seek to make africa in its own image in
terms of values and i think those two
things are the ones that have connected
these two continents however i would
look at the recent statements uh by the
leader of china as more public diplomacy
that it meant to our clear peace leaders
of the continent and generally the local
population that has been complaining
about uh increased chinese influence in
ways that sometimes disadvantages
especially local labor uh
anthony goldman i'll be coming back to
for this question both to you and to
andy mock bouncy can i just bring in
earlier uh in the week we showed on al
jazeera a report where chinese
mine officials had sanctioned the
beating of a local man in the democratic
republic of congo for stealing cobalt
rock this was videoed it was shown
widely
we've reported on it
when andy mock says that you know
china's initial thoughts are always
about empathy with africa being equal
with africa understanding the needs of
africa when you see video like this it
undermines that argument doesn't it
about what china really wants and this
is the you might say the tag that
western media western governments grab
hold of and say you see this is what
china is really about
well it does and i think that there may
be a difference between uh policy from
headquarters and what actually happens
on the ground and certainly i think that
that's not the only instance you know
everybody is a cameraman now and there
have been a couple of instances from you
know from west africa as well similar
things where
relations uh at the cold face almost
literally uh do deteriorate quite
sharply i mean i think that that's
probably true with uh lots of foreign
companies but the idea that china is
somehow very distinct and and much
better in that regard is belied by the
reality of events in a lot of places on
the ground including those where it's
been captured in the way that you
describe and it's also true that in
certain uh
in some of those countries where china
has had its most active engagement it's
also become a domestic political issue
in in zambia there's certain populist
mileage that political parties make in
making an issue out of chinese
investments and
other elements of chinese policy because
although china uh was never a colonial
power obviously in in africa there has
been quite a lot of immigration from
china as part of its uh
growth and uh
of economic ties with africa and i think
you know upwards of a million
people have moved to africa over the
last 20 years from china and that's
concentrated in a few places and
sometimes not always with
positive results these are difficult
changes to make and not changes that
happen easily or overnight andy can i
come in for a brief comment from you on
that as well
no i would absolutely agree i think it's
intellectually dishonest uh to attribute
the
actions or the misdeeds of an individual
to a government policy i mean we all
know
that those of us that i'm sure every all
of us have interacted with large
organizations whether governmental or
for-profit
and one of the big challenges and
especially
for chinese enterprises working in a
place far from home with a different
language different culture different
customs
uh that these are very very difficult
circumstances i think it would be
surprising if some sort of
mistakes or abuses did not happen we
also need to recognize mining is a
difficult business as well so these are
unfortunate and i think that they should
not happen in an ideal world but
certainly uh as far as i know there is
no policy on the chinese side to condone
these types of actions
hassan kanenji can i just come back to
you now of course uh xi jinping has
promised a billion doses of the
covert 19 chinese-made vaccine to the
continent
obviously a welcome donation but it
comes in the context of the world health
organization who promised under kovacs
that africa would be looked after yet
western countries did nothing did very
little we've been reporting it for 18
months they've done something but not
enough not enough for
mutations to appear
china again
helping out as much as it possibly can
where do you stand on this do you see
this as some sort of medical bribery in
any shape or form
no i would say the extension of
geopolitics uh you know that are going
on especially between uh the russo sino
russian alliance and the transatlantic
alliance and i think uh while there was
a lot of effort especially from the
previous administration in the united
states uh to paint china a lot more
negatively as a source of covet 19. it
has worked its way into lots of hearts
and minds of people especially the
developing world and so what this
donation means is people are going to
pay attention to those soft power
aspects of china which it has been doing
more excellently despite some of the
propaganda that has been shared of
course with regard some of the human
rights violations in terms of isolated
incidents and it's going to i think to
go a very long way because the west has
largely not been as present and
especially europe
united states has been trying but of
course i think it's grappling with its
own issues and there are there's a lot
of vaccine and nationalism that has
limited
the ability of the west to actually
engage africa in a way that is going to
be appreciated in the long term i'm
coming very close to the end of the
program andy mock can i just come back
to you soft power how important is that
in terms of chinese policy is it a word
that's used is it a phrase that's used
and do you see this vaccine
donation in that same sort of
area
absolutely so i think soft power is
sometimes referred to in the chinese
context is discourse power and in a
world where we face global challenges
and global responses are required the
ability to be heard taken seriously have
one's views and opinions seen as
legitimate is vital and i think one of
the big issues we're seeing here is in
places with market-driven economies like
the us uh they are not able to overcome
the structural limitations of for-profit
companies wanting to protect their
bottom line whereas china
is able to act uh in the interest of its
country and the world and i think this
is an important factor in its increasing
discourse power well i'm sure we'll be
coming back to the subjects not too
distant future sadly there gentlemen we
have to leave it hassan kanenji anthony
goldman and andy mark in nairobi london
and beijing gentlemen thank you for
joining me here and thank you for
watching as well you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website at
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story from me sahel rahman and
the inside story team thanks for your
time and your company
[Music]